yesterday marked the 50th anniversary of
the first Selma March one of the pivotal
moments which led to the Voting Rights
Acts but but voting rights in this
country much like John Travolta's hair
are still very much a work in progress
there are the obvious obstacles for many
Americans such as increasingly
restrictive voter ID laws but there's
also the less obvious ones as Congress
was reminded just this week as we
commemorate the 50th anniversary of the
march on Selma this week and the
subsequent passage of the Voting Rights
Act I want to once again call to the
attention my colleagues here in Congress
that there is still American citizens
today who do not have equal voting
rights these are citizens of Americans
island territories the US Virgin Islands
Puerto Rico Guam and the Northern
Marianas yes American citizens living in
u.s. island territories do not get to
vote for president that's the kind of
unsettling fact that deep down you
probably knew but chose not to think
about like the fact that the dog from
full house is definitely dead by now
you're proving my point
more than four million people live in
the US territories more than 98% of them
are racial or ethnic minorities and the
more you look into the history of why
their voting rights are restricted the
harder it is to justify because it goes
all the way back to an America first
acquired them the United States flag is
flying over these lands and so some
people said well doesn't that mean
American laws apply in 1901 the insular
cases basically the judgment of the
Supreme Court was that the new
territories were inhabited by quote
alien races and they may not be able to
understand anglo-saxon laws therefore
the Constitution doesn't have to apply
Wow
alien races can't understand anglo-saxon
principles I find that condescending and
I'm British
we basically invented patronizing
bigotry I do so wish we could explain
the concept of voting to them but during
me they're savage little coconut brains
would probably just collapse
I'm assuming it's coconut milk in there
will soon see wacky stick is not set off
some alarm bells for you the man who
wrote the lead decision in the first of
those rulings was justice Henry Billings
Brown who fun fact also wrote the famous
separate to put equal decision in Plessy
versus Ferguson and even he suggested
these exceptions to the Constitution
should only stand for a time as in a
temporary arrangement but it's been a
hundred and fourteen years it's like for
over a century America's computer has
been saying an update to your country is
available and we've been clicking
reminds me later again and again and
again so tonight let's look at voting
rights in the territories and we'll
begin in Puerto Rico whose citizens are
Americans a fact that comes as a
surprise to a shocking number of people
as we learned when Sonia Sotomayor was
named to the Supreme Court
Sotomayor a Bronx native is the daughter
of Puerto Rican immigrants she was a
first generation American the daughter
of Puerto Rican immigrants a daughter of
Puerto Rican immigrants she is the
daughter of Puerto Rican immigrants
she's the daughter of Puerto Rican
immigrants no she isn't she's the
daughter of Americans who moved from
Puerto Rico in Puerto Ricans are
immigrants anyone anywhere immigrant
broke could you help me immigrate
Apartments on Saturday I need to
immigrate a couch up two flights of
stairs Puerto Rico has more American
citizens than 21 US states but less
voting rights than any of them and
whether or not they choose to become a
state it's a little weird that while
they're making that decision they have a
delegate in Congress who can't do much
my constituents cherish their US
citizenship and have made countless
contributions to this country yet they
cannot vote for president have no US
senators and send one delegate to the
house who has a voice but no vote in
this chamber it's funny infantilizing
when discussing national legislation to
give Puerto Rico the same status as a
six year old voting on where the family
should get to go on vacation
oh what's that Timmy Narnia okay
Colonial Williamsburg it is there and
that you were heard Timmy you were heard
and the same voting rights restrictions
apply to the residents of Guam the
Pacific territory that unequivocally
sounds the most like a Batman punch
[Applause]
[Music]
there is there is nothing not to love
about Guam it is a beautiful island in a
strategically important location for the
US military
so much so their bases currently occupy
over a quarter of Guam's land and yet
the residents of Guam have absolutely no
say in general elections for their
commander in chief which is even harder
to swallow when you consider this
according to guan's Office of Veterans
Affairs at least one in eight adult
Guamanians is a veteran among the
highest percentages of all US states and
territories Guam gives a quarter of its
land and as much as an eighth of its
people to the US military at this point
the American flag should really just be
a guy from Guam waving an American flag
and yet due in part to their lack of
full voting rights those veterans are
shamefully underserved in 2012 Guam
ranked dead last in per-capita spending
on medical care by the US Department of
Veterans Affairs or the VA it's called
the PTSD program look here so it tells
me you to enter my address five options
here but the closest one so far looks
like Hawaii it's three thousand eight
hundred three miles point twenty two
miles that is disgusting the only person
who should have to travel 3,800 miles
for treatment should be a Beverly Hills
housewife flying to Colombia for
unapproved lip injections derived from
cobra venom but but the amazing thing is
just because Guam residents aren't
allowed to vote for president doesn't
mean that they don't go on hold a straw
poll every presidential election and
they're registered voter turnout is
actually higher than that of the rest of
America
and to misquote the words of the great
philosopher Lil Jon turn out for what
that's a great song but just just
imagine how it must feel to have the
desire to vote but know deep down you're
going to be ignored actually you don't
have to imagine it because let this
Gwang voter tell you it's terrible I
mean I I believe it's not fair you know
we're all citizens of the United States
I wish somebody change that okay that
sounds sad but at least on Election Day
that woman gets to wear the incredibly
special I voted and wish it had actually
counted sticker but amazingly Guam still
gets more respect from the US government
than American Samoa as was proven a
little while back when a u.s. member of
Congress was tasked with introducing
their delegates inai Faleomavaega the
chair recognizes the gentleman from
American Samoa mr. king hello and Binga
somolia listen I get his name is a
little difficult but you cannot
mispronounce American Samoa there's a
Girl Scout cookie like the state of thin
mint asipi that would be ridiculous but
watch how gracious Americans Somalia's
delegate was in his response Thank You
mr. speaker to American Samoa
that is class that I do not have because
if I were him I'd responded thank you it
is a privilege to be here in Waffle
tandino great United sporks of Eluga
boink
American Samoans not only lack voting
rights they lack a little something
extra to the US Constitution grants the
citizenship to everyone born on US soil
except in one jurisdiction American
Samoa
in the South Pacific it is a u.s.
territory but people who are born there
do not automatically get US citizenship
I think don't even get automatic
citizenship meaning the American part of
American Samoa is really just a title
that doesn't mean anything like People's
Choice Award nominee or social media
experts just devoid of meaning and that
fact is especially shocking when you
learned that American Samoa a territory
that cannot vote for a president who
could send it to war is also home to the
top Army recruiting station in the
country so now I'm thinking the American
flag should be a dye from American Samoa
waving a flag with a guy from Guam on it
waving the American flag and because of
their status as non-citizens many
veterans have to carry around a
humiliating reminder that they are not
equal in the eyes of the law so this
here is my US national passport the very
last page of the passport makes it
uniquely a US national passport and
makes me look like I'm an outsider I
think it did me if that means me as a
person I think that's right they're not
citizens but Nationals which means they
can't run for president serve on a
federal jewelry or depending on where
they live even become a public
schoolteacher so that they're kind of
like off-brand citizens they're they're
Americans in the same way that these are
fruit loops or this is dr. pepper you
could pretend is the same thing everyone
knows it's worse five American Samoans
are actually suing the government to
change this rule but the Obama
administration has fought them by citing
the insular cases from earlier which
suggest that American Samoans like all
residents of the territories can be
given fewer rights because they belong
to alien races differing from us in
customs and modes of thought and that's
a tricky argument to win in the face of
this kind of evidence where you from I'm
originally from American Samoa and what
do you do for a living I'm a soldier in
the US Army
I joined straight out of high school and
it was something to serve my country and
to give back I'm active service we just
got back from deployment to Afghanistan
for nine months all the way
[Music]
[Applause]
just to be clear that is an Afghanistan
war veteran moving an audience to cheers
and at least one judge to a partial
orgasm with a rendition of a Rihanna
song on a show called America's Got
Talent
if that's not American I don't think one
has ever existed of complicated issues
surrounding what the precise status of
all the US territories should be and
what the people who live there would
prefer but surely when it comes to
denying Americans the right to vote we
have to find a better reason than citing
a 100 year old legal decision written by
a racist that was always supposed to be
temporary and I'm not saying this will
be an easy thing to do I'm just saying
we've figured out a lot more complicated
things in the last hundred and fourteen
years think about it
we invented television we eliminated the
measles and then for some reason
brought them back again WrestleManias
and those things are logistical
nightmares and you know what else we
figured out how to fly and if we
can work out how to climb inside metal
Birds slip the bonds of this earth and
soar through the air to visit these
territories we should be able to work
out how to ensure the four million
people who live there get adequately
hurt
you